The Real Moby Dick
While you’ve probably at least heard of
the fictional great white whale, Moby Dick,
you may not know that it was actually partially
inspired by a real life white whale that destroyed
over 20 whaling ships and reportedly survived
encounters with another 80 or so.
The massive 70 foot long albino sperm whale
was named Mocha Dick and was one of the two
whales that inspired the novel Moby Dick.
Mocha Dick was given his name as he was first
sighted off the coast of Chile near Mocha
Island; the latter “Dick” part of the
name is thought to have simply been after
the practice of naming certain deadly whales
common names like “Dick” or “Tom”.
The whalers that first spotted him attempted
to kill him, but he survived the encounter.
Over the course of the next 28 years, Mocha
Dick earned a reputation as one of the most
cunning and feared whales in the ocean.
During that span, he was spotted and attacked
by at least 100 whaling ships.
He successfully destroyed around 20 of those
ships that attacked him, escaping all but
the last.
According to famed explorer and writer Jeremiah
N. Reynolds, Mocha Dick finally met his downfall
after observing a mother whale whose calf
had just been killed by whalers.
The mother whale first attempted to herd her
calf away from the whalers after it had been
harpooned, but soon the calf went belly up.
When the whale realized her calf was dead,
she turned on the whalers and attempted, unsuccessfully,
to destroy their ship.
Instead, she herself was harpooned and mortally
wounded before she was able to strike the
ship.
Upon observing all this, Mocha Dick decided
to get in on the fray and also attacked the
whaling ship directly after the missed hit
by the mother.
Mocha Dick successfully destroyed one of the
smaller whaling boats, but was injured in
the process by a harpoon.
Here is the account of what happened after,
according to Reynolds who collected the story
from the first mate of the whaling ship that
finally took down Mocha Dick:
“Making a leap toward the boat, he darted
perpendicularly downward, hurling the after
oarsman, who was helmsman at the time, ten
feet over the quarter, as he struck the long
steering-oar in his descent.
The unfortunate seaman fell, with his head
forward, just upon the flukes of the whale,
as he vanished, and was drawn down by suction
of the closing waters, as if he had been a
feather.
After being carried to a great depth, as we
inferred from the time he remained below the
surface, he came up, panting and exhausted,
and was dragged on board, amidst the hearty
congratulations of his comrades.
Overpowered by his wounds, and exhausted by
his exertions and the enormous pressure of
the water above him, the immense creature
was compelled to turn once more upward, for
a fresh supply of air, And upward he came,
indeed; shooting twenty feet of his gigantic
length above the waves, by the impulse of
his ascent.
He was not disposed to be idle.
Hardly had we succeeded in bailing out our
swamping boat, when he again darted away,
as it seemed to me with renewed energy.
For a quarter of a mile, we parted the opposing
waters as though they had offered no more
resistance than air.
Our game then abruptly brought to, and lay
as if paralyzed, his massy frame quivering
and twitching, as if under the influence of
galvanism.
I gave the word to haul on; and seizing a
boat-spade, as we came near him, drove it
twice into his small; no doubt partially disabling
him by the vigor and certainty of the blows.
Wheeling furiously around, he answered this
salutation, by making a desperate dash at
the boat’s quarter.
We were so near him, that to escape the shock
of his onset, by any practicable manoeuvre,
was out of the question.
But at the critical moment, when we expected
to be crushed by the collision, his powers
seemed to give way.
The fatal lance had reached the seat of life.
His strength failed him in mid career, and
sinking quietly beneath our keel, grazing
it as he wallowed along, he rose again a few
rods from us, on the side opposite that where
he went down.
‘Lay around, my boys, and let us set on
him!’
I cried, for I saw his spirit was broken at
last.
But the lance and spade were needless now.
The work was done.
The dying animal was struggling in a whirlpool
of bloody foam, and the ocean far around was
tinted with crimson.
‘Stern all!’
I shouted, as he commenced running impetuously
in a circle, beating the water alternately
with his head and flukes, and smiting his
teeth ferociously into their sockets, with
a crashing sound, in the strong spasms of
dissolution.
‘Stern all I or we shall be stove!’
As I gave the command, a stream of black,
clotted gore rose in a thick spout above the
expiring brute, and fell in a shower around,
bedewing, or rather drenching us, with a spray
of blood.
‘There’s the flag!’
I exclaimed; ‘there! thick as tar!
Stern! every soul of ye!
He’s going in his flurry!’
And the monster, under the convulsive influence
of his final paroxysm, flung his huge tail
into the air, and then, for the space of a
minute, thrashed the waters on either side
of him with quick and powerful blows; the
sound of the concussions resembling that of
the rapid discharge of artillery.
He then turned slowly and heavily on his side,
and lay a dead mass upon the sea through which
he had so long ranged a conqueror.
‘He’s fin-up at last!’
I screamed, at the very top of my voice.
‘Hurrah! hurrah! hurrah!’
And snatching off my cap, I sent it spinning
aloft, jumping at the same time from thwart
to thwart, like a madman.
We now drew alongside our floating spoil;
and I seriously question if the brave commodore
who first, and so nobly, broke the charm of
British invincibility, by the capture of the
Guerriere, felt a warmer rush of delight,
as he beheld our national flag waving over
the British ensign, in assurance of his victory,
than I did, as I leaped upon the quarter deck
of Dick’s back, planted my waif-pole in
the midst, and saw the little canvass flag,
that tells so important and satisfactory a
tale to the whaleman, fluttering above my
hard-earned prize.”
The other whale that helped inspire Moby Dick
was a huge sperm whale that destroyed the
Essex in 1820 around 2,000 miles west of South
America.
Herman Melville learned of the story of the
Essex when the whaling ship he was on, only
100 miles from where the Essex was destroyed,
encountered another whaling ship, which had
the son of the Essex’s first mate, Owen
Chase, aboard.
After the Essex was destroyed, the 21 man
crew took refuge on three small whaling boats
that had almost no supplies to sustain them.
Their choice at this point was to head for
known habitable islands that they feared were
populated with cannibals, 1,200 miles away,
or head for South America 2,000 miles away,
but about 4,000 miles by the quickest sailing
route due to the winds that time of year.
Despite this distance, they chose South America.
Ironically, as you’ll read shortly, their
choice of not choosing the much shorter route
for fear of cannibals, resulted in some of
them resorting to cannibalism.
During their journey, they did at one point
encounter an island that they more or less
stripped of its resources to help sustain
themselves.
They also left three men behind there, at
the time thinking likely to their doom, to
help conserve supplies and increase the chances
the others would make it back.
What followed was an incredibly gruesome tail.
As they traveled, they steadily lost crew
due to lack of nourishment.
At a certain point, they were forced to give
up burying their men at sea and, instead,
began eating them and drinking their blood.
They eventually even had to resort to not
waiting for someone to die, but, rather, drew
lots for who was to die and nourish the others
with their body.
In the end, 95 days after their ship was destroyed,
they were rescued with only five left alive
aboard the two remaining small ships (one
was lost along the way with the crew never
heard from again).
Miraculously, the three left on the depleted
island, though near death when eventually
found, survived the event.
Bonus Facts:
• While today Moby Dick is considered a
great work of literature, in its day, it wasn’t
very successful and only earned Melville $556.37
and less than 3000 copies were sold over the
40 years or so between publication and Melville’s
death.
• A common whaling nickname in the early
19th century for whales that spout blood after
being harpooned (meaning they were likely
soon to die) was “Dennis”.
• Jeremiah N. Reynolds not only helped inspire
Moby Dick through one of his narratives, but
also helped inspire Edgar Allan Poe’s The
Narrative of Arthur Gordon Pym of Nantucket.
This was through Reynolds’ lectures on his
notion that the Earth was hollow.